bruno pour vous pour la police que
s'est-il passé hier soir on sait que
sait on des riens qui fait très beau il
a énormément de buts n'a pas marché
malheureusement là malheureusement
c'était si tu n'avais eu la pelouse mais
il a vu les affaires de droit commun
classique quoi c'est donc avec une
tentative de vol donc il est comment il
est il en train de rouler alors il roule
alors d'après ce que je sais les
éléments qui sont donnés c'est que
traverse le bois de boulogne pour
rentrer chez lui où je ne sais quoi
il s'arrête à un stop et là la version
est délicate on va voir avec l'unc est
ce que l'on va donner inquiète c'est que
les inserts voiture et je suppose qu'ils
roulent pas avec une clio de 1986 mais
donc le ces voitures modernes sont quand
même sécurité si tu t'arrêtes un point b
sont fermés automatismes ce qui est
étonnant c'est que ça se passe au feu
rouge et que la personne ont réussi à
rentrer la voiture bursa c'est une
première interrogation mais l enquête le
dira à suivre c'est quoi votre version
alors donc il est tranquillement en
train de rentrer chez lui quand tout à
coup
quelqu'un ainsi mis dans sa voiture
voilà lui lui prennent évidemment vous
avez l'habitude de tous de mettre le
téléphone d'un portefeuille la cause sur
le central bon les gars lui prendra que
ce matériel là et ensuite bien italie
deal avec lui pour lui donner 200 euros
et lui demander le rendement c'est une
tentative de vol c'est tout simple avec
extorsion de fonds ont fait la
qualification c'est ça donc en fait il a
deal avec qui
aller à personne avec la personne
d'accord avec la personne qui s'était
immiscé dans le véhicule tout à fait aux
questions dans le véhicule la personne
lui voler son portable et son et voilà
qu'à dérouler et puis abandonné il lui
dit bon je négocierai option roulent
ensemble
c'est les infos qu'ils sont donnés
officiellement
il faut pas il faut pas beaucoup de
mains
il négocie 1 en disant je te file de sa
roja moi mais mes affaires tout
simplement
l'histoire paraît un petit peu banken
très sincèrement mais bon à suivre
encore une fois c'est la qualification
c'est une qualification droit commun
placé il dirait tentative de vol
puisqu'il atteinte à des réseaux de
téléphones en milieu hostile
et
ensuite une extorsion de fonds puisque
garden est quand même de sa séance une
extorsion de fonds et de très belles a
alors su qu'il a eue le footballeur la
vigilance d'appeler rapidement la police
mais bon pied que les policiers mais
alors ils vont faire une déposition le
dans un premier temps il n'a pas porté
plainte et non il a fallu faire
signalement il a porté plainte en fait
de journée c'est donc en fait l'histoire
c'est qu'elle aurait donné il y aurait
donné les 200 euros est terminée exact
extorsion de fond ça représente une
excursion l'enfant porté plainte pour
les 200 euros c'est ça ouais bah oui et
puis en même temps pour nom c'est
surtout pour retrouver l'individu ne
sert pas ne faut pas que ça se
renouvelle mais exactement alors
l'individu et il a déjà donné une
description de l'individu bah il a donné
des éléments factuels je pense concerne
alors lesquels
[Rires]
avec samantha qui et c'est surprenant
canario bois de boulogne dans une mesure
pareille dans sa salle d'attenté bmc ça
c'est quelqu'un qui connaît très bien la
vie de bernard - samantha va nous donner
sa version dans un instant et gilbert
n'est selon le joueur qui sortait d'une
opération dont quadrillé partenaires
pour le club au parc des princes faut le
dire il est dix malades et parents boîte
boloni rentrer chez lui et selon lui
quand la personne est rentré dans la
voiture il a cru que la personne était
armé adacore le joueur qui elle avait
les mains d'un bâton de coiffes au
calibre je ne sais pas mais les mains
étaient posées devant il a cru que la
personne avait une arme est en fait donc
la personne lui a dit voilà moi je vous
garde tout est effectivement il a
négocié rendez-moi télé d'accord
philippe ils sont retournés au point de
départ il se retourner au point de
départ et il n'a pas porté plainte et ce
qui se dit quand même c'est que s'il a
porté plainte aujourd'hui c'est parce
que ces sorties et donc il n'avait pas
d'autre choix que de porter plainte
voilà d'accord alors déjà merci ça monte
à d'être avec nous à une donné votre
version dans un instant ça fait des
années que vous êtes au bois de boulogne
connaissez vous en connaissez tous les
secrets oui alors c'est un bois de
boulogne le déclic c'est un bois où
vraiment au cours
et parfois et la nuit c'est vrai que ça
se transforme
en un lieu voilà un peuple est content
et les voilà voilà voilà vous n'allez
pas chercher du bois la nuit là-bas
merci
à bord avant qu'on parle de la version
de votre version quand ça se passe déjà
ça monte à depuis combien de temps vous
êtes là bas vous il paraît que
j'arrivais en 95 avec vous êtes vous
êtes gamin de 16 ans depuis vous avez 14
ans je commence la prostitution à 14 ans
la rochelle on est content ou pas 14 ans
j'en ai 46 un an presque 32 10 j'ai vu
que j'ai tiré les regards et que les
hommes avaient des intentions vermand
bien sûr ce qu'on appelait la pédophilie
mais on ne met pas à l'époque maintenant
que comment vous en est arrivé là en
fait en bois de boulogne je viens d'une
famille ouvrière on n'avait pas
forcément beaucoup de moyens on
travaillait pour prendre de l'argent de
poche et ben voila j'ai fait mon argent
à moi tout seul en autonomie totale
jamais craqué n'y a rien à quoi bon se
retrouvent au bois de boulogne c'est
tout seul là bas j'arrivais de la
rochelle ouais mari et j'ai fait des
petits boulots vente de de lithographie
en porte à porte ce à quoi on suit
lâcher les chiens recevoir avec le fusil
à on n'est pas payé fait toute la
semaine on vous dit on vous paye la fin
la semaine et puis barre d'accord la
boîte a disparu et au bois car elle tape
un boulet n'ayez pas peur vous êtes tout
seul la nuit comme ça en fait on a peur
de quoi si on va là avec la peur au
ventre on fait rien et ça fait quoi donc
travaillé au bois de boulogne 26 ans 26
ans on voit d'où viennent tous les soirs
bain beaucoup moins en ce moment parce
que avec tout ce qui se passe en ce
moment il ya des agressions la ba voila
non mais pas forcément de deux filles
envers les clients ça n'a rien à voir
non mais de
deux groupes de cinq dix personnes 3 en
bois qui agressent les fini qu'à
l'extérieur par les sacs à main par les
cheveux les viols donc vous avez vous
dira qu'il faut dire qu'il ya du viol
non et pourtant ce n'est pas parce qu'on
est parti tourner nue c'est pas parce
qu'on est une prostituée ou et vous
savez pourquoi parce que beaucoup sont
en situation irrégulière et ont peur
qu'on allant commissaire rapporté
patcher l'immigration que les roms c'est
ça aujourd'hui on part là qu'il ya de la
police et le soir dans le bois de
boulogne nous sommes allant de nuit du
16e j alors moi je trouve dans la rue
route de la porte dauphine à la porte
des sablons ça fait deux ans et demi
qu'elle est dans le noir il n'ya pas un
lampadaire de lui mais je vous parlais
policiers je ne parle pas d'eux mais les
policiers on les voit pas si les
policiers passent en donnez vous falloir
fera aussi vite pardonné au juste alors
comment ça se passe une journée au bois
de boulogne ou juste pour après vous
avez une parmi ses pairs et de votre
arrivée sa durée commence à se faire
donc c'est qu'on vous en parle ils vont
semer en tenue parce qu'on arrive on
prend les transports c'est fini l'époque
du taxi on arrivait à des princesses
déjà maquillé ben non on prend les
transports en commun comme tout le monde
on chausse ses talons son mini jupe en
se préparant se conditionne et on
commence
on commence à caen bat d et jusqu à
gambader vérité fois jusque dans les
métros et quand on n'a pas fait de
l'argent qu'on n'a pas décollé ben on va
jusqu'au premier métro le matin ah ouais
et des fois pour rien faire on ne rien
faire littéralement vous avez déjà été
agressé j'ai été agressé plusieurs forts
coups de couteau coups de cutter au
visage
non on est agressé on se tapait dessus
insulté répondu j'avais pensé arrêter
faire autre chose que vous êtes méritant
pourquoi qui vont engager quelqu'un qui
est transgenre ça me cantonne à un
certain cran une certaine quantité ou
catégories de d'emplois je vais pas
travailler dans la nuit j'ai trop fait
la fête la nuit je sais les dérives j'ai
pas envie de ça voici je veux travailler
c'est mais ce que vous posez
j'aime moi la prostitution j'ai jamais
fait sa force et vous dites j'aime ce
que je fais bien sûr voilà je donne du
plaisir je peux prendre du plaisir faut
pas croire qu'une prostituée prend pas
son pied en ces faux ou à l'épaule mais
non non on peut prendre son pied on peut
prendre son plaisir mais moi j'aime bien
quand quelqu'un arrive qu'il est fatigué
de sa semaine de boulot qu'il a galéré
qu'il arrête la subit et bah qui
repartent avec le sourire wayne ne
serait-ce que ça je me dis je bosse j'ai
fait mon travail j'ai bien accompli ma
tâche et j'étais rémunéré en échange des
biens bravo merci alors ça fait des
années donc vous êtes au boulot nous on
connaissait tous les secrets il y avait
de surcroît d'aidé sont bien sûr fait
les deux noms à ce que vous avez déjà
parce que on va parler de gaffe à ce que
vous avez déjà croisé des personnes
connues mais nous avons
politiques acteurs chanteurs wi ex de
tf1 également
[Rires]
ses films sont passés sur tf1 oui
d'accord annoncés en heures mais on va
parler non mais y en a eu beaucoup
beaucoup et puis il y en a qu'on ait
oublié le maintenant mais qui était
connu à l'époque et puis qui reviennent
maintenant
on a des casseroles on a des dossiers
ils ont des casseroles au cul est coincé
on le sait mais on ne peut pas dire sont
dit on perd on perd toute crédibilité si
vous voyez je suis devant les caméras en
plus tu parles une [ __ ] elle embrasse un
client a balance pas du direct
une règle des législations c'est comme
ça c'est pas si mal en soit la question
que je pose c'est parce que c'est vrai
qu'à dix d'entre eux connu on dit il
faut pas besoin de ça pour quoi ils
viennent et pourquoi ils n'auraient pas
besoin de ça no mi ser qui pouvaient ils
ont ils ont énormément de succès et bébé
vous croyez que le succès n'est pas du
tout certain ils ont pas envie de
s'afficher ici je vais dans le bois
c'est discret je fais ma petite affaire
je fais ma vie danger je me casse ah oui
bien sûr égaux et avec la plus belle
actrice du monde elisabeth hurley et
pourtant il a été pris
si vous saviez le nombre de jeunes qui
se marie très jeunes qui sont en couple
qui ont des enfants qui sont heureux en
commun et puis bah un moment elle estime
avoir fait son devoir conjugal là les
migraines à chaque fois qu'il est en vie
est ce que sylvain il va pas ça coulait
sur l'oreille ce que c'est vrai qu'à des
paparazzi qui viennent parfois ici sur
surprendre des célébrités alors ça j'ai
jamais eu ça par contre j'ai des flics
qui sont venues des caméras infrarouges
parce qu'ils aient mais avec notre
accord parce qu'il venait pour pister
les gens etc et on les en remercie parce
que vous faut dire ce qu'est la police
c'est quand même bien son travail voilà
encore incertain
mais pas dans les années 80 des dérives
alors on va revenir sur cette affaire de
ce footballeur agressé au bois de
boulogne on a eu la version bruno pomart
donc apparemment ils auraient été dans
sa voiture quelqu'un se serait introduit
dans sa voiture une prostituée elle lui
aurait dérobé son portefeuille ainsi que
son téléphone et il aurait négocié 200
euros pour pouvoir repartir
et voilà et récupérer ses affaires donc
il n'a pas porté plainte si c est la
porter plainte ou pas après quatre ans
après coup d'accord quel est votre vous
je sais que vous connaissez toutes les
histoires là bas ça monte à quelle est
votre version je viens de les croire gt
r du tout
mais moi je bosse toute l'émission ah
oui alors oui généralement pas du tout
c'est quoi ta version doit pas du tout
justement comme disait monsieur
les voitures de ce modèle là de se
classent la fermeture centralisée
automatique d'accord vous mettez le
contact c'est fumant alors non c'est pas
vrai parce qu'ils vont mettre un petit
truc parfois
vous jure que c'est vrai même dans les
bois
il a bien dit que c'était un feu non
mais ça peut arriver part ça il faut
configurer fermeture de ses portes je
n'avais pas confie t il a bien dit que
c'était arrêté à un feu j'ai ce que ces
organismes situés d'un travail à la
proximité d'un feu déjà d'une pourquoi
parce que c'est parce que ça peut
provoquer des accidents ou des
carambolages adacore oui donc ça faut le
savoir je comprends oui il faut le
savoir oui mais voilà jean tous les sens
et ne met pas sur l'ondé le feu ou des
croisements tient le monde et
on essaie de se mettre en retrait au
moins à 20 mètres la collision est temps
de s'arrêter rémy déjà durci s'arrêter
au feu on va en pleine nuit il n'y a pas
dix voitures devant lui c'est faux
d'accord donc moi je vous dis
franchement c'est quoi l'intérêt sur le
c'est pas possible qu'il a négocié
peut-être une passe avec la fille il a
fait le kéké la 12e' wesh les
footballeurs je gagne des sous je suis
pété de thunes il lui a sorti un billet
de 50 balles mais il a dû ouvrir un
portefeuille et est arrivé ce qui devait
arriver je pense mais ça je veux pas
incriminer qui que ce soit parce que
c'est humain on travaille pas beaucoup
c'est galère en ce moment mais quand
même oui monsieur baudis ya le braquer
c'est ça d'ici a le bras cassé le bras
en bras qu'avec une arme on braque à
cuba c'est bon ça reste une occasion
ghalem c'est pas prouvé que ce qu'elle
est et qu'elle permet parce que madame
sait combien la passe alors sévère ou la
technique le train autour de la peep la
mort
merci bernard
gentil gentil moi j'ai franchement du
mal à croire qu'une star du psg comme ça
qui est une star mondiale en délaissent
leur suivi par 4 millions personnes sur
les réseaux prennent le risque
aujourd'hui je dis pas il ya 20 ans
quand il est moins deux réseaux sociaux
d'aller au bois de bouleaux à savoir
bien sûr avoir une relation sexuelle on
va pas se mentir je dis pas que c'est
son cas il ya plein de footballeurs qui
ont aujourd'hui des relations avec des
femmes il existe d'autres moyens pour le
faire et voilà j'ai du mal à croire
qu'il ait pris ce risque là mois la
version que j'ai eu c'est qu'ils
habitent effectivement à
neuilly-sur-seine qui n'était au parc
des princes qu'entre chez lui et le parc
des princes et le bois de boulogne qu'il
est passé qui se tenait un peu de
manière ostentatoire cinquième essai
montre son portefeuille et c'est dans sa
voiture et que cette somme est rentré
dans sa voiture et lui c'est quelqu'un
de très gentil on le voit dans les
interviews etc voilà il a voulu et il
était contraint lui donner de l'argent
la vraie question tout le monde se pose
ce soir c'est samantha est ce que ça
vous fait plaisir de retrouver votre
fils
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
il a 30 ans
mais ça ne m'est cher de retrouver
d'autres chefs d'état vient d'avoir avec
les chéris juste cette affaire n est
complètement folle bruno pomart ça est
ce que c'est ça ça arrive souvent ce
genre de chose ou pas mais c'est
fréquent de manière à ces problématiques
dans la boîte boulonné c'est très très
fréquent mais pas que dans votre boulot
d'ailleurs nous sommes tous les faits de
droits communs comme on disait dans
paris et entre non c'est mais ce qu'est
ce qui est surprenant encore une fois
c'est que comme tu dis il est super
gentil m'a fait moi ça ne viendrait pas
à l'idée de passer dans le bois de
bobine avec max martin et même si je
suis gentille que j'ai vraiment peur de
dire que quelqu'un vienne à personne je
la fais rentrer dans ma bagnole ça
franchement je l'aurais pas fait c'est
une smart là on a mienne
je pense pas qu'il en soit
travailler votre version ça me perds ma
version c'est qu'il s'arrêtait pour
consommer d'accord pour consommer il
s'est arrêté parce que de déverrouiller
une porte comme ça c'est soit on a peur
on n'est pas tirée par la personne ne
voit pas l'intérêt dans le bois le bois
qui est qui et qui kaki et sombre on
s'aventure pas mon est un mec seul
peut-être en écho aux tournées en est
mais n'est ce pas un tueur mais on
s'arrête pas comme ça qu'une voiture
hors de prix surtout il s'est levé de
montils avait de losail sur lui un beau
téléphone quelle idée mais quelle idée
donc l idée franchement et je ne crois
pas du tout à ce que la ti et ouvert la
porte d'elle-même parce que je vous dis
les véhicules maintenant avec la
technologie de maintenant ça se
verrouille automatiquement
alors je n'y crois pas matsui chine sans
préjugés c'est vrai qu'à quelque chose
de bizarre c'était aller de la reine
marguerite s'est passé exactement
non mais oui bah quand on est allé la
reine marguerite sont
attachés à cette heure-là le club les
brief c'est une star internationale il a
joué à manchester united et joe psg l'a
signé cinq ans le club leur dis faites
attention il ya des endroits où on va
pas donc c'est vrai que cette affaire
elle est bizarre c'est c1 ce serait un
hasard incroyable qu'à cet endroit là où
il n'y a pas il n'y a pas d'autres
agressions on n'a pas relevé récemment
de plein d'autres personnes en plus
c'est vrai que ça paraît quand même je
ne préjuge de rien ça paraît quand même
hallucinant soit simplement un hasard
qu'un joueur du psg à cet endroit la
soie entre guillemets agressé voilà ça
paraît surréaliste honnêtement oui mais
le problème c'est qu'il est marié marié
la maison près de la rue bories non mais
c'est sur le problème il problème voyage
ils sont comme on le dit et gilson ils
sont tous briefé c'est pour ça que de la
sécurité de l'ensemble des joueurs ils
sont briefés sur toutes ces choses là
évidemment mais pourquoi sa fuite et
comment sa fuite parce qu'en fait c'est
par ce passage qui porte plainte à sa
fuite sa fuite par apparemment ça fumait
même j'ai même de la police il ya
toujours des informations qui fusent de
partout donc patience qui préviennent la
presse kiwi a toujours mais bien sûr ça
a toujours existé c'est à dire il s'est
fait prendre les deux il a donné les
deux sens mal qu'il a su en fait c'est à
dire qu'il a su commencent à fuiter
parce que si là il aurait pas porter
plainte s'ils savaient pas fuite a ouais
c'est ça que leur gréement sa fuite et
c'est pas là alors gardons c'est lui qui
a décidé de porter plainte oui mais
c'est parce que sa fille dont il a fait
un signalement à la police mike pour
pour se dé se dédouaner je ne sais pas
avait dit tout à l'heure il a justement
comme il avait vu que ça commence à
percer oui la porte éclater un bris à
percer à laurent qui portent plainte
signalement ait porté plaine parce qu'on
peut faire un signalement mais pas
nécessairement porter plainte - fait
après d'accord juste vous c'est déjà
arrivé ce genre d'affaires ou pas du
tout que je vole non non mais non pas
vous mais
j'ai réclamé ça dans votre fils
[Rires]
est-ce qui s est déjà arrivé ce genre de
cas où une jeune femme voilà se sont
introduits dans une voiture volée
et n'importe quoi il faut colère pas
dire que ça n'est jamais arrivé se
serait voilà donc ces faits horribles
aimé mais où faut pas faire passer des
pubs pour des malhonnêtes quoi que ce
soit il peut y avoir un moment de
discorde ou de trou le voilà depuis la
personne part en live elle part en
vrille mais c'est exceptionnel c'est
exceptionnel c'est rarissime donc moi je
dis franchement vous avez déjà eu des
relations sont cités avec des grands
sportives ou des choses oui relation
tarifée un oui oui oui ah oui les plats
ont visiblement oui non c'est vrai qu'on
avait des genres des directives
politiques l'agrégateur
chanteur oui parfois non à huy
hommes de médias vous vous reconnaissez
les gens ici
non mais non personne
[Rires]
sans discrétion mais je vous demande
quoi vous gagnez par mois en moyenne
deux par rapport à avant madame avons
combien à la belle époque là bas n'est
pas pouvait se faire entre 150 200 euros
par jour d'accord en n'y allant pas tous
les jours bien sûr la g et saad a été
divisé par cinq par cinq voire six voire
depuis la loi de pénalisation des
clients on a on est en galère lac en
souffrent on se fout mais vraiment on
souffre beaucoup de fiba se retrouver à
la rue ou à partager un studio à 3 pour
pour se regrouper pour payer loyer pour
bouffer pour voilà et galère certaines
sont dans des états catastrophique
niveau santé la saison pas le temps
elles fondées me complète puis elles ont
pas le temps de prendre soin d'elle
voilà et on a vu des gens à la rue où
vous travaillez tout seuls n'y a
personne qui vous êtes seul comme ça
vous arrive est le seul bien sûr
toujours tout seul jour où américain
cran d'arrêt lacrymogènes bas ça je suis
prête ouais c'est ça
apparaît à côté ou quatre doigts au cas
une voiture faut toujours prévoir on
sait jamais vous savez dans le bois dans
une rue qui n'est pas éclairée ouais il
ya un bruit derrière vous a pas le temps
de nous retourner on se passe que par
yves couture et de prêt on est au taquet
faut pas croire mais il faut ce soir
vous travaillez non non ce soir non on
est un petit peu avec votre fils les
retrouvailles
préfet vous préfériez pas la réouverture
des maisons closes
si on était considérés déclaré reconnu
et que les cotisations conversos reese
par exemple les 20 % sur chaque client
après on touche une retraite je veux
bien mais avant de lancer les maisons
closes penser déjà aux retombées
derrière monsieur quand ils ont fait le
plein ce sont des crises on dit c'est
pour vous protéger les filles ouais y'a
pas eu d'accès au logement social n'y a
pas eu de de parachute on va dire ou de
2,2 de matelas pour amortir la chute on
s'est retrouvé dans la merde dans la
merde moi j'étais dans un hôtel je paye
60 euros par nuit je devais une semaine
d'hôtel j'ai dû partir je me suis sauvée
on fait comment vous n'êtes plus
verbaliser maintenant dans rosbank non
moi j'ai connu la fin de cette époque là
mais heureuse maintenant alors vous avez
les grandes stars est ce qu'un jour il
ya une personne voilà qui voudraient de
mal faire un jour à un cachet incroyable
ouais c'est vrai je cois époque des
saoudiens ses 2500 euros la soirée non
ah ouais et je les ai connus à l'époque
défense et 25000 30 as one way les voyez
ils passaient deux trois mois d'été sur
paris apprend les voyez pas pendant neuf
mois oui c'est incroyable quand on parle
des grandes stars on s'imagine qu'avec
leur succès leur notoriété leur train de
vie n'ont pas besoin d'aller voir des
prostituées quand vous expliquer qu'ils
viennent vous voir là c'est vrai que
vous voulez c'est là mais ça vous
fait danser sur la fonctionnelle de de
la pro du capitou autre chose et puis
voilà généraux
discrètement on sait qu'à des escort
girls aujourd'hui qui ressemble bien sûr
des appartements etc oui mais les
appartements vous êtes des filles qui
font la webcam et on s'est passée la
caméra est branché et vous sais pas si
vous êtes filmés au bois vous dites yens
soit tous les chats sont gris comme on
dit oui on voit rien on sait pas où les
îles avoine chine la voiture
oui quoi tout ça dépend quand ils
ressortent même
l'espace série voilà
entre un petit peu de respect pour votre
fiston
[Rires]
servante ah oui et non mais c'est
pas avait l'air heureuse en tout cas
évident mais moi je s'épanouit moi je
suis heureuse moi je me dis qu'il ya
toujours pire dans la vie ouais c'est je
me lamente je tombe je m'écroule allait
faire ça toute votre vie jusqu'à ce que
je puisse lui jusqu'à ce que je sois
plus bankable et puis voilà et pourquoi
mais je me fixe pas de limite d'âge tant
que je plaies gisait le jour où on me
dira oh [ __ ] ça toi de me payer aux
[ __ ] fouta que je me retire je veux
pas attendre ce moment là comment vous
jouez aggraverait xia bin on a la chance
en france d'avoir le minimum vieillesse
là je ne sais pas quoi il s'appelle
projet des 1000 euros et moi je suis
dans un logement social juste cette
chance là l'année dernière avant le coup
vide donc merci et ben je sais que si je
suis monsieur je touche au minimum
vieillesse je pourrais vivre normalement
normalement normalement pas en faisant
des folies mais normalement d'accord bah
je m'en contenterai isabelle moi j'ai un
amis animateurs je ne dirai évidemment
pas le nom qu'il va régulièrement au
bois de boulogne ah ouais d'accord cela
il ya tous vos amis de 136 p
tous les gars animateurs collation
améliorée ni ouest sont quatre et au
graff champions modelage
ats ces comices et les animateurs santé
de tournage qui a maintenant trois
quatre épisodes dans la journée ils font
les tenues et où vincent avait connu une
master de bouffe
de la
revue dans des bacs roulants l'arrêt
mais bon
non mais c'est quoi il ya des animateurs
qui sortit le tournage qui venaient nous
voir bien sûr encore max et away qu'on
maquille et oui bien sûr on te
refinancer des liens ouais mais ici
aller parce que ben allez tourner toute
une journée comme ça cinq épisodes à la
suite sébastien
ouais mais voilà comment vous
les mecs là où
aulas et ses tours ils sont là mon
célibat
et ben quoi
est ce que est ce que vous avez essayé
de faire autre chose parce que tout à
l'heure bien des yeux en tant que
transgenres sais pas j'ai travaillé dans
la restauration j'ai travaillé dans
certaines choses l'équipement qui ment
pas convenu parce que moi je supporte
pas de me lever le matin d'avoir des
heures moi mes horaires je les fais
quand je vais le jour où j'ai pas envie
d'y aller j'y vais pas c'est vraiment ça
qui vous avez fait ma liberté ces
machines il faut pas croire que la
prostitution si on est emprisonné
peut-être les fils de réseau certifié
mois chez une liberté totale de mon
corps de mes actes une mémé pratique je
n'ai pas de souteneur de la vie est
passée là parce que là pardon mais je
veux mon argent de temps là vous dresser
un portrait un petit peu il dit
je ne sais pas désir faut aussi dire que
y'a de poya des jeunes femmes et ils
veulent avez certainement
raison j'en parlais je me mets à
soutenir seulement ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est qu'il faut pas mettre ce terme là
les filles de réseau en avant se sait
que 10% de la population des prostituées
dont communauto postés à chaque fois en
tout cas le rouge intéressé c'est
bernard pech la concurrence défi de
l'est elle est réelle mais quelle
concurrence puisque moi je suis trans
une fille et c'est une fille une femme
lavage un ouais le lien si vous ne le
propose en plus il vient voir moi oui
alors une chatte y va
on s'est quittés sur les mines
[Applaudissements]
c est aussi on en avion l'envers
c'est bon merci pour cette sur cette
affaire en tout cas on espère qu'il n'a
pas été trop traumatisés andere race que
c'est un joueur que j'adore en plus un
non mais c'est vrai voilà donc il va
bien tout va bien pour lui ben je
demanderai à la personne qui a en charge
la sécurité des joueurs du psg qui est à
quand une amie intime mais bon voilà
parce que tu parlais
pas qu ils nous disaient tu c'est normal
je suis pas censé être là parce que
c'est une règle de mise c'est comment
les cars touristiques de chinois à
l'époque il passé dans le bois c'était
interdit parce qu'il se faisait
racketter faisait voler les montres
dépouiller les appareils et ben le des
sportifs du parc des princes ont eu
vraiment dit c'est en orient est pas
censé être là parce que on a une
assurance qui nous couvre du parc des
princes jusque chez nous mais si on fait
une altercation par le bois de boulogne
qui s'il arrive quelque chose au bois de
boulogne on n'est pas couvert vous aimez
lire et à mon sens que pendant sa vous
le savoir aussi c'est pour ça que je
vous dis il n'est pas passé comme ça
elle n'a pas vu de la lumière il est
rentré il est passé pour pour quelque
chose de précis